rusia vive hoy una intensa jornada de
movilizaciones protestando para pedir la
liberación del líder opositor alexéi
navalni las movilizaciones se llevan a
cabo en 96 ciudades y en las situadas
más al este ya se han producido
detenciones y en algunos casos
importantes choques con la policía aquí
en moscú la arteria principal del centro
la avenida tú eres acá ya ha amanecido
cortada entre la plaza púshkinskaya que
es donde está convocada esta
manifestación ilegal y el kremlin se
trata de evitar que los manifestantes en
un momento dado intenten avanzar hacia
el palacio presidencial algunos testigos
incluso han visto entrar en los accesos
a moscú a vehículos blindados el líder
opositor ha lesionado y ha pedido a sus
a sus seguidores que salgan hoy a la
calle pero el alcalde de moscú ha pedido
tranquilidad todo el mundo les ha
recordado que estamos todavía en
situación de pandemia y que desatender
las normas de seguridad podría provocar
un repunte en los contagios